sapete che la parte più difficile di un
video e la partenza perché sai si ciberà
tutti ragazzi e basta non so come
dirvelo un po tipo l'ho già sentita una
volta quindi basta e quindi io sono in
un momento della mia vita in cui non mi
sento di dire a tutti ragazzi inizio
divido ma devo iniziare ogni volta in
modo strano
altra cosa non cercate di vedere il
cervello in quei frame precedenti perché
non lo troverete ben più di ragazzi come
lui che questo video sono fa vj e oggi
siamo tornati su ipad
questo hebron placement tornati sulla
tavola tecnologica sembrati sull'ipad
perché giudei giochiamo a una cosa di
decisamente migliore di tutto il resto
dei giochi presenti sulla piazza ovvero
kicked ebadi
non so se mi servono le cuffie realtà
visto che sto giocando l'ipad però non
ho idea di che cosa sia questo gioco
però tra i più scaricati
l'ultimo gioco più scaricato era fashion
fai da te quindi per farvi capire se
questa volta siamo su chi chiude bandi
che questo questo personaggino che tu
puoi malmenare cep limite quando mina la
giornata storta scaricate l'applicazione
posso staccargli la testa a posto usare
le cose per fargli del male va bene
vediamo non mi dà tanta soddisfazione
proviamo altra roba c'è veramente poi
malmenare questo questo essere perché
deve ma poverino ma cosa abbia fatto a
cristo qualcuno vi spiega i perché hanno
creato questi giochi con il problema
quanto sadici blog ma lo puoi uccidere
proprio ma che carino
ti fai guadagna soldi i due danno i
soldi educativo questo gioco la parola a
maxi la parola soldi se le dice due
volte di fila nome non ti monetizzano il
video però non fa niente perché il gioco
non mi sembra proprio family friendly ma
va bene così mi piace questo gioco mi dà
un sacco di soddisfazioni e conquista la
mia prossima mossa
questa è questo un sacco di
soddisfazioni
quasi quasi preferivo fashion star moda
creativa lo tengo lì perché un bel
ricordo
ora ragazzi siccome chi che debba di
solo per leggere il nome ti partono 20
euro direi che possiamo switch aree
gioco anche se l'idea mi era quella di
fare di 2 bardi e direi di rispolverare
un attimino versione migliorata di de
baldi che conosciamo già tutti è che il
rum se non lo conoscete
forse è meglio avevo portato questo
gioco un sacco di tempo fa era tra un
annetto è già passato un anno e ho perso
dei capelli problema è che adesso è
tolto è rimasto con l'ultimo set up che
ho fatto e soprattutto il record del
mondo tra ceva vede il mondo no però
c'erano anche l'altra volta e skin non
abbiamo più figata vabbè vi introduco a
quello che è il mondo di questo gioco
per chi non lo conoscesse visto che da
tanto è un gioco mi devo reintrodurre
anche io praticamente tu devi creare in
questa stanza del danno per questo per
questo omino più danno fai più punti
accumuli in poche parole basta roba
c'era l'ultima volta tipo il cannone a
ghiaccio il cannone ad acido ma dato che
sono usciti secco ma non c'erano
l'ultima volta ma scusami li play e da
un botto che non ci gioco qui ma guarda
che figo è bellissimo lo hanno
migliorato il sacco non sapevo perché
perciò con la novità è che l'hanno
migliorato tantissimo ma cavolo ma è un
anno che non cito e non me lo dite che
hanno migliorato la donna che fanno e
ciò rega allora voi che siete 5 milioni
se avete più occhi di me quando
migliorano un gioco e ditemelo che lo
rifaccio no mamma mia
porca vacca per lasciare che youtube è
il mio lavoro dovrei vederlo io detta
voli su dettaglio a chi se ne frega
ora che è bellissimo ma cavolo hanno
aggiunto un sacco di roba a saperlo
subito queste sono anni di tattiche di
questo gioco portate a quello che vedete
adesso cioè non è non ero così forte una
volta faccio schifo invece 3.600 di
punteggio al primo tentativo vi assicuro
che non è male anzi andiamo anche oltre
dopo un po che sparano le armi ragazzi
finiscono quindi è normale stanno
sparano più una certa che sommando le
fiammanti tutto il tempo
e tu devi fare più punti possibili in
questo lasso di tempo non è molto family
friendly come gioco ma chi se ne frega
mia finito 4.200 punti a un tentativo a
caso ti imparerò a volare ti imparati
l'italiano probabilmente avevo anche già
detto per ora togliamo tutto 3 quesito
ridotto di ieri e allora lanciagranate
io sto provando le le robe che non
conosco perché l'ultima volta che ho
giocato non so se non mi pare di aver
visto sta roba quindi lancia granate
giusto per curiosità
queste comunque che ti sbattono la parte
alta sono importantissimi va bene direi
che possiamo provare così prima di
lanciagranate perché ancora non li ho
visti a pensare belli
vabbè quanto male quanto belli non
celate fanno malissimo contro bar mamma
mia che dove per il cavolo vi giuro non
so come fa a essere così figo vabbè
comunque lancia granate sono fortissimi
e credo che come tattica anche se
abbozzata errata non è niente male
questa il problema è che i lanciata e
costano veramente tanto prefiggo e
divertente non so se batte il record di
prima non penso a te che ho fatto quasi
quattromila devo arrivare a 4000 per
battere record iniziale non so se lo
batterò mai perché è veramente difficile
però sicuro stavano scherzando
niente l'avevo visto sopra stavo
scherzando ok il alta il mio record è
questo qua però non lo batteremo mai
perché per farlo bagato il gioco
continuavo a cadere all'infinito una
roba assurda all'acli rating non solo a
togliere tutto tranne il pavimento
perché pavimento mi mi sa che lo tengo
sempre così a questa parte perfetto
adulterio dovrebbe essere buono come
tentativo proviamo
madonna zeus ok si sono scassate
perfetto è durato molto meno del
previsto però ok è però adesso non so
più niente che fa danno porca vacca
pensavo facessero molto più danno di
chiusi prof
va beh tu spiegami come hai fatto come
questa la fusione di dragon ball baobab
è stato molto carino però lasciamo perle
vabbè ragazzi proviamo lascia che non me
la ricordo per niente proprio allora
cose nuove gravitazione 0 pedro
sbloccare anche un sacco di roba però
non ho ancora fatto niente cannone ad
acido cannone a ghiaccio a fighissimo
lanciafiamme mitragliatrice a chi armata
va va
macché armata mito l'attrice prova prova
coi mitra trici non so quanto farlo
che male che male fa quella roba lì che
la riesce veramente che cosa fatta danno
randon era posto facendo un botto di
danno anche così è
vorrei dire non siamo arrivati a 4000 di
certo ma anzi sono andati molto vicino
eccolo crude ma come soprattutto il
record veramente da vabbè ha tra l'altro
queste cose le sblocchi quando vai oltre
questo conteggio coatte me lo dici
adesso devo ribattere il record provando
a fare quello che ho fatto l'ultima
volta non so se ci riesco perché non mi
ricordo come ho fatto lavoro cancellato
all'inizio se ci avete fatto caso
allora tentativo number one
vi sembrerà una cagata ma herat è così e
molto easy e poi devo mettere il portale
con i portal let's go
mi pare che fosse così non c'è
nient'altro che questo via
ecco perché sennò era era finito in
tragedia già da subito castrati uomo ma
no aspetta ho sbagliato questa pagina
dalla parte sbagliata ma porca vacca è
cosa non si fa per fare il punteggio
massimo
proviamoci non sono sicuro di riuscire a
replicare starò la prova le noi proviamo
fatevi vorremmo star lì una vita però
vai non lo so se funziona però dovrebbe
io nel dubbio vado a prendermi un caffè
scegliamo tra non so 20 minuti ok è
passata un'ora ho fatto tante cose di là
ho letto tre libri non è vero non so
leggere lo record grazie ho sbagliato un
laser e ho sbloccato mini laser e
acquario con piranha va bene testimoni
subito acquario con pirani ma cos'è
cos'è è bellissimo qual è allora
prosperity o nei 21 qua tipo cos'è sta
roba di addio
allora innanzitutto fammi vedere come
funziona il piranha poi mettiamo anche
il mini laser ma fichissimo sto male
cambia anche la musica quando ma dai è
bellissimo
va bene allora quello più tesla immagino
perché il peso dovrebbero tenerti fermo
dentro l'acquario cioè almeno quella è
la mia idea
tesla tesa ma non ho capito ma finiscono
i piranha una certa o continuano così
che se non finiscono c'è tanta roba
i miei laser non so cosa sia non
approviamo immagino sia una roba simile
al tesla un po più forse fa più danno
non lo so ma per la costa di più mi
laser costa di meno non lo so la roma e
poi vediamo se funziona quello che devo
fare esatto madonna quanto danno si
prende quando va dentro la e bellissimo
si di un sacco di danno ho messo il palo
esattamente dove lo volevo perfetto c'è
questa è una tattica paurosa
rimangono i piranha attaccati anche dopo
e ma è bellissimo
fa veramente un bordello di danno avuto
un'ottima idea l'unico problema è che
una volta finito al laser non fa più
troppo danno prefiggo sono orgoglioso di
me stesso ogni tanto giuste idee ragazzi
concludo qui però vi sia piaciuto
comunque riscoprire sto gioco è stata
una cosa a fighissima tutti gli oggetti
nuovi che abbiamo sbloccato li proviamo
poi nel prossimo episodio proviamo anche
a battere il record anche se non penso
sia possibile visto quanto danno sto
facendo però ci proveremo
quasi due ragazzi sapete più ci hanno
dato mi piace anche vari social come
descrizione sono resi schiavi e non ci
vediamo allora siamo ragazzi
[Musica]